well let me sort of on on the AIC do you
think there's some interesting questions
there though to solve for the open
source community in this case so like
alignment for example
um or the control problem like if you
really have super powerful you said it's
scary okay what do we do with it so not
not control not some fast control but
like
if you were then you're gonna see some
guy
or gal release a super powerful language
model open source and here you are
George cost thinking holy okay what
ideas do I have to uh combat this thing
so what ideas would you have I am so
much not worried about the machine
independently doing harm that's what
some of these AI safety people seem to
think they somehow seem to think that
the machine like independently is going
to rebel against its creator so you
don't think you'll find autonomy no this
is sci-fi B movie Garbage okay what if
the thing writes code basically voice
viruses
if the thing that writes viruses it's
because the human
told it to write viruses yeah but
there's some things you can't like put
back in the box that's that's kind of
the whole point is it kind of spreads
give it access to the internet it
spreads installs itself
modifies your BBB plot sci-fi not
real so I'm trying to work I'm trying to
get better in my plot writing the thing
the thing that worries me I mean we have
a real danger to discuss and that is bad
humans using the thing to do whatever
bad unaligned AI thing you want but this
goes to the
uh your previous concern that uh who
gets to Define who's a good human who's
a bad human nobody does we give it to
everybody and if you do anything besides
give it to everybody trust me the bad
humans will get it
it's always the bad humans who get power
okay Power
and uh Power turns even slightly good
humans to bad sure that's the intuition
you have I don't know
I don't think everyone I don't think
everyone I just think that like here
here's a the saying that I put in one of
my blog posts it's when I was in the
hacking world I found 95 of people to be
good and five percent of people to be
bad like who I personally judged as good
people and bad people like they believed
about like you know good things for the
world they wanted like flourishing and
they wanted you know growth and they
wanted things I consider good right
I came into the business world with
comma and I found the exact opposite I
found five percent of people go ahead
and 95 of people bad I found a world
that promotes psychopathy
I wonder what that means I wonder if
that care like uh
I wonder if that's anecdotal or if it uh
if there's true to that there's
something about capitalism
wow at the core that promotes the people
that run capitalism that promotes
psychopathy that saying May of course be
my own biases right that may be my own
bias is that these people are a lot more
aligned with me than these other people
right yeah so you know I can certainly
uh recognize that but you know in
general I mean this is like a common
sense Maxim which is the people who end
up getting power are never the ones you
want with it